let's go next to um
where are we going next why don't we go
to
um let's go to win
from thailand this could be interesting
when you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can okay sorry
uh yeah uh so i'm a big fan of your show
and i have a question on taxes
sure um so i see that you are for
universal healthcare and
and i think you made a video a while
back called
how will liberals pay uh free stuff or
something like that
and yes now just so the audience knows
that the title was tongue-in-cheek
because
in the in the the substance of it is
we have answers for how we're going to
pay for it so just so everybody knows
that the title was kind of a satirical
title
right yeah and i believe the listing and
you can correct me if i'm wrong but
i think the list includes getting rid of
the bush tax cuts
uh reducing military spending and and i
believe one of it was
uh raising the marginal tax rate up to
70
and if i'm not wrong you stated
something about business expenses being
tax deductibles
and and you know that businesses are
more likely to avoid
getting taxed 70 and rather get taxed um
30
or however much the tax deductible loss
may be so my question is
if businesses are choosing the ladder
which is to avoid the 70 marginal tax
rate
uh how will medicare for all uh or
universal
education uh and health care be funded
so
i i appreciate the question you're
with total respect you're a little bit
all over the place on different aspects
of that video
and of how things are sort of funded so
let me see if i can kind of take
take a few things apart here first the
list of
ways to raise money that i listed in
that video
are options and they don't necessarily
all go together and they don't all
necessarily in practice
go to fund specific things it's just
here's a whole bunch of ways
where without hurting ourselves we can
raise revenue if that's what we choose
to want to do
in terms of top marginal tax rate 70
that was not me saying let's raise the
the
rate on everybody who's currently in the
top tax bracket to 70
that was just a reference to academic
papers which
suggests that if you create more
brackets with increasingly high
marginal tax rates that top rate which
would be for people making
millions or even tens of millions of
dollars being at 70 percent
seems to be what increases government
revenue the most
so that's not directly related to paying
for healthcare you with me so far
i see yeah yeah yeah so then and then
the last part of your question was
if businesses do avoid if businesses
are incentivized to avoid higher taxes
how does that generate revenue in what
the point of the story was if the way
that you
avoid a higher tax rate as a business
is by hiring more people or investing
in the business that is stimulative the
point is you're not just
taking the profit and saving the money
so
it generates more revenue by encouraging
businesses to actually invest the money
rather than save it
ah okay thank you very much and what
would your
your main uh proposal be to fund
medicare for all in universal health
care
i don't i don't have a particular
proposal
for how i would do it i'm sort of
agnostic on it there's a lot of
different ways the first thing is
i'm not even first we have to have a
full understanding
of how whatever healthcare system we
want to implement would work
because depending on how it would work
we may already have money that is going
towards the current system that would
just be shifted and that's going to
impact how much money we actually need
so this is like a major major topic
i don't have just like hey we just tax
everybody 50
and that's it like it's not that simple
and i don't have such a simple solution
but there's a ton of academic work on
this and one of the things we have to
understand is
if you look at the total cost of health
care right now which includes
a whole bunch of bureaucracy through
medical billing
uh prices that have to be artificially
high to account for people that have no
health insurance and will never pay
all of this different stuff there's a
ton of money in the system already
that if you eliminate that waste becomes
available to offset some of the costs
right off the bat and then the amount of
money you have to find goes way way down
wow okay well that was very helpful
thank you very much david
i really appreciate the call um all the
way from thailand i have never
thought that you would i would get the
the chance to call you actually
no we love thailand thailand we love
what part of thailand are you in
um bangkok oh okay uh i hear that the
night markets are fantastic in bangkok
yeah coveted rates right now isn't
really looking good we have an
authoritarian government so we're trying
to wake up
i get away uh get our way through and
stuff yeah
i understand all right win i i really
appreciate the call
okay thank you very much david win from
thailand
substantive beautiful audio
i mean wow wow just a lot happening
there
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman